he's called it his life's work the Duke
of sussex's hatred of the Tabloid press
is well documented his argument against
photographers and newspapers dates back
to the death of his mother and today a
court heard how every aspect of the
Duke's life was written about his lawyer
saying nothing was out of bounds well
this week Prince Harry will have his day
in court
Duke of Sussex is fighting Fleet Street
Billy mirror is underway are the events
surrounding his mother's death presents
the media bringing damages claims
against the mirror group he claims the
tabloids tapped his landline and hacked
hacked his phone Harry's court papers
make huge allegations this is Prince
Harry versus the papers round three
hi very good evening I'm Jonathan
Samuels and today Prince Harry has begun
his biggest battle yet with the British
press the Duke of Sussex is accusing
mirror group newspapers the proprietor
and publisher of the Daily Mirror the
Sunday Mirror and the Sunday people of
unlawful information gathering between
1991 and 2011 which his legal team says
resulted in a number of Articles being
published it's not the only newspaper
publisher that the Duke has a case
against Rupert Murdoch's news group
newspapers the owners of the Sun and
Associated newspapers who publish The
Daily Mail but this is the first time
Prince Harry has gone to trial the first
time he's given evidence as a witness
and the first senior British royal to
appear in the witness box since the
1890s coming up we'll bring you all the
latest from the trial with updates from
our team who've been inside Court will
have the opening remarks from the
lawyers including allegations about
Princess Diana's phone being hacked
claims described as total speculation
and Prince Harry's lawyer insisting he
does not have a vendetta against the
Press
plus we'll look ahead to the main events
the Duke of Sussex expected to arrive at
the high court tomorrow and take to the
witness box
we'll be analyzing what we know so far
with our special guests Persephone
Bridgeman Baker media lawyer and partner
at Carter Ruck and Paul Kong new former
editor of the Sunday Mirror Deputy
editor of the Daily Mirror and a media
commentator
good evening to both of you thanks for
your time so why don't we start with a
look at what is being claimed by Prince
Harry now he says he would often get
missed calls or hang up phone calls from
unknown numbers
he wouldn't receive voicemails family
and friends said they had left and
unheard voicemails would appear as
already played
he says private information appeared in
newspapers with no reasonable
explanation for how it could have been
discovered and photographers would show
up at private events and locations
well let's bring in our Royal
correspondent Laura bundock who's been
at court all day Laura the Duke didn't
turn up did he and he was accused of
time wasting but nonetheless we still
did get a lot of detail didn't we about
his allegations
we certainly did and I think the very
testy start to proceedings today gave us
all a real taste of what Prince Harry
can expect tomorrow I think there is a
basic rule in all court cases don't get
on the wrong side of the judge and it'll
be interesting to see tomorrow if we're
given reasons as to why Prince Harry
wasn't in court we just don't know why
he wasn't here today he certainly will
not want to have annoyed the judge this
case is really important to him we've
been hearing today how alleged hacking
engulfed his whole life from a very very
early age and not just his life but the
lives of those who were closest to him
including his late mother Harry knows
that by coming here tomorrow he will
draw huge attention to not just the case
but his wider cause this cause to try
and reform to change the media landscape
he is of course though taking a huge
personal risk and what will be
interesting tomorrow is seeing how he
performs his legal team we know will
have advised him as much as they can
when it comes to the questions he can
expect to face tomorrow but they can't
tell him they're not allowed to tell him
what to say he'll be prepped but not
coached and there is a significant
difference he's of course someone who's
very used to the spotlight isn't he but
he certainly isn't used to the
atmosphere inside Court 15 here and I
think the preparation he can get himself
ready for is nothing compared to the
pressures he's going to face when he's
in the witness stand tomorrow it will be
very interesting to see what happens
when the mirrors legal team press him
probe him goad him and I think we'll all
be judging Harry not just by what he
says tomorrow but perhaps by what he
doesn't say as well yeah it's going to
be a fascinating day Laura thank you
very much indeed why don't we get in
into the detail of what was said in
court today though joining me in the
studio Persephone Bridgeman Baker media
lawyer and partner at Carter Ruck and
Paul con you former editor of the Sunday
Mirror and former deputy editor of the
Daily Mirror a media commentator as well
really great to to have you with us um
just before we chat I want to just tell
everyone what the judge had to say when
Harry didn't turn up in court the judge
is Mr Justice fan court and he opened
proceedings this morning by saying I am
a little surprised at the direction that
the first witness is not going to be
available today Persephone what did you
make of that legally should you have
been there so today was about opening
statements first and foremost and it is
slightly unusual for particularly if you
only have one witness
um on on the claimant side for them not
to be attending court on on that first
day but then Harry's not exactly your
usual witness so
um I imagine that his Barrister thought
perhaps they wouldn't get off opening
statements today and the evidence was
start tomorrow and indeed I think they
got about about an hour perhaps of one
of the reporters evidence today yeah so
we'll hear from him tomorrow
um Paul lawyers for the newspaper of
course really making hay about this yes
Prince Harry might do well to apologize
to the judge tomorrow but whether he
will see that will that happen I I
rather doubt it but if if I were
advising him to a PR point of view I
might say sorry malud
um but it's interesting I mean I mean
today was it struck me as a bit like a
sort of spicy hors d'oeuvre to a rather
hot curry coming up tomorrow yeah
interesting way of putting it um well we
certainly Heard lots of examples today
didn't we of Articles which Harry
believes the information was obtained
using unlawful methods this is what the
princess Barrister David Sherborne
referred to an article in the Daily
Mirror back in 1996 which claimed
Princess Diana was upset while visiting
Prince Harry on his 12th birthday you
can see the article all there Diana so
sad just look how young Harry looks well
Harry's that lawyer said you will see
this is less than a year before the
tragic death of his mother not a hint of
reticence of publishing details of the
ill health of someone close to him all
of which were private and not publicly
shared and Persephone it just shows
doesn't it that these allegations go
back a long way they really do but
something which the defendants team were
very keen to make clear today is that
there is in fact no evidence of actual
hacking and they talked about the
inferences which they came in the Duke
of sussex's team are encouraging the
court to draw and I think that was
something which came across very
strongly from those opening statements
today and you know the the defendant
mirror group almost saying what is there
to see here we don't have it we don't
have any evidence no inquiries never
come out of the police met police
investigation either
um you know we're going to need the
burden of proof is on the Duke of Sussex
and we need to see more here yeah that's
a good point that Paul isn't it that how
he does have to prove that his phone was
physically hacked that his mum's phone
was physically hacked he certainly has
to convince the judge that there's
enough evidence of course a lot of
people it's interesting the social media
reaction I've been looking at is people
don't always realize this is a civil
action
uh rather than a rather than a criminal
case they talk about guilt and innocence
in fact that the judge could come up
with a more nuanced you know result here
but but but in reality it is Harry's
side his legal team are relying very
much on the inference or trying to if
it's the judge of the inference of the
mirror of settled 100 million pounds
worth of of the claims so therefore this
must be a pattern and you can't exclude
Harry from being one of their targets
the mirrors con teams you know Converse
argument is in fact where's the proof
where's the doc documentation you know
specifically about Harry while
acknowledging there is a history you
know undeniable history of settlements
yeah well Harry's um legal team also
quoted from some handwritten letters
that have been written uh by Princess
Diana to the Entertainer Michael
Barrymore it's something I found out uh
particularly fascinating because she was
apologizing in those letters for details
of their private conversations being
published uh in the mirror we can we can
have a look at what we said in court uh
today this is what Diana said back in
the day nobody knew about our
conversation phone call how deeply sorry
I am that what I considered to be a
private matter has become public
property so that's what she wrote to
Barrymore today Harry's lawyer said it's
plainly that Daily Mirror has been
listening into the voicemail messages
that's how they knew about secret and
highly sensitive meetings Barrymore was
struggling with coming out as gay
addiction to drink and drugs therefore
obviously of interest to newspaper
reporters but it does go to show doesn't
it that it might be circumstantial
evidence but it's pretty strong evidence
that a very personal very private
message between two people who knew each
other intimately suddenly appears in the
paper how else could it have happened I
mean that's that's exactly what the
claimants case is
um I mean I I think it's we've got to
see what happens tomorrow in
cross-examination which is going to be
absolutely fascinating to see um really
what what Harry can come up with by way
of of evidence or more than just trying
to create that that inference that we've
been talking about yeah well let's I
tell you what I'll get your thoughts in
a second Paul because I want to see what
was said in court in in defense this is
what mirror group newspapers had to say
Andrew Green they're disputing the claim
he said Mr sherborne's suggestion that
mgn journalists hacked Princess Diana's
phone is total speculation without any
evidential basis whatsoever the letters
you were shown to Mr Baron were not
evidence of voicemail interception and
there is no other evidence plainly no
such finding can be made making that
point Paul yes but Princess Diana had
people she trusted and spoke to her in
her own Inner Circle so it's not I mean
the mirror lawyers will argue that that
you it wasn't merely Diana and Michael
or Barrymore who were the parties to
this conversation you know that it was
other people it could have been around
and passed it on
um and certainly in the in the book
reporting royalty that that I mean a
co-author of which could just come out
this week certainly we we talk about you
know the history of actually drawn the
so-called War of the Wales is when both
sides appointed
intermediaries who would brief the Press
including a couple of occasions to me
Diana herself so so it's not it's not
impossible that other people knew about
those conversations and and leaked to
the press the burden as the mirrorable
lawyers will argue you know it can't be
proven that that's the only way that the
Barrymore Princess Diana conversations
reached reached theme reached the papers
well what's the strategy here then do
you think well a lot of the mirror's
case is just that some of these stories
were taken from other newspapers so it's
not simply that there were the
possibility of leaks outside of um
hacking or blagging or bugging or any of
the other different allegations which
are being put in this litigation and
Harry's multiple other litigations
against
um against different Publishers but um
they are the mirror group are saying
that there's plenty of reasons how how
this information could have come to to
the press and not simply because of the
allegations that are being made by
Prince Harry yeah because of course not
just about phone hacking this is it it's
about lots of Nefarious methods that we
used in full information gathering um
actually acknowledged from the start of
course you know they're saying that
there's only one incident and there was
there was a payment to a private
detective to unlawfully gather
information about Prince Harry they've
conceded that but that's being blamed on
a rogue journalist rather than what
Harry's trying to build is this sort of
idea of a campaign of this being
undertaken and you know this
infiltrating at the highest points of
the mirror group and trickling down
through the journalists and being a sort
of method of operation which is what
he's really seeking to to try to make
out here yeah good that's good point um
let's talk about something else that we
said in in court then another incident
that Harry was involved in Mr Sherborne
referred to a Daily Mirror article back
in September 2000 regarding a trip that
he took to the pub for his birthday uh
Mr Sherborne said Prince Harry turned up
unannounced at this small Pub no
journalist is coming along to explain
how the photographer was able to be in
the right place at the right time Paul
you've been a newspaper hack you've
worked with journalists you've worked
with reporters
um if Harry's phone wasn't hacked how
else would reporters and and Snappers
and Paparazzi have known he was going to
be there I I don't know and we haven't
yet heard a discussion in court as to
who took the pictures how for example it
could have been a free you know often
you'd get a call from somebody saying
you know so-and-so's celebrity is in the
pub doing this doing that and getting
drunk going up whatever it might be and
they that they ring up a newspapers news
desk and you if you have freelance
journalists but who might live not very
far away they can they can go around and
take and grab pictures so in a sense
it's that isn't conclusive
I mean the whole thing here is being
built as a pattern you know that there
can't be there can't be the bird the the
sheer of volume is the is the Harry case
in fact you know means there must have
been hacking going on the mirror gonna
say well no prove it
Hey sir yeah I mean that's the thing
it's all about the burden burden of
proof isn't it and um one of the uh big
issues for Harry
um and we're going to talk about this
now is is his relationships especially
as a young man and we know that uh many
of the articles that the Duke alleges
were sourced from unlawful information
gathering relate to that relationship
that he had with Chelsea Davies first
proper girlfriend really um this is what
was said a number of Articles were
published over the course of the
printers relationship and they discussed
uh these articles here you can see we've
got a various various um uh articles
that were printed in in the mirror and
the Sunday Mirror um Harry is a Chelsea
fan is one there's uh when Harry met
Daddy
Harry's girl to dump him really personal
stuff another one here Chelsea is not
happy uh also when they were splitting
up down in the dumped
um and this is this is a big a big issue
for Prince Harry isn't it because he
says that so many of his relationships
whether they were with girlfriends or
with his family or with his close circle
of friends they deteriorated because he
became increasingly paranoid didn't he
and he says that it wasn't his friends
tipping off the papers but actually it
was phone hacking and these illegal
memes well certainly it is the common
thread of all the many cases that have
been settled by various newspaper groups
you know over over hacking is that is
that it destroyed relationships
destroyed trust between members of you
know of a family or their Social Circle
who actually was was leaking on them was
that was obviously the the suspicion and
I mean that's a pattern but I think with
Harry it's it's he sees it as a sort of
crusade to change the Press you know and
others would see it as a sort of morbid
Obsession but uh but it's it's
interesting it's interesting he is
making making great play of the effect
it had on him psychologically now
we all know he's a man of physical
courage from his time time in the mid in
the military but facing a KC tomorrow
analytically it'll be a big very
different test from appearing on soft
interviews with for Netflix or with
Oprah Winfrey it's going to be a totally
different atmosphere and challenge for
him tomorrow yeah what do you think
Persephone is this about uh reform of
the press or is it about revenge well
you touched upon the distress aspect and
actually the damages that Harry's
seeking in this litigation and damages
are the only remedy really that he will
be granted and what could be granted and
those damages are for the most part and
I think this is why the evidence is
moving in this direction as for the most
part based upon distress so you have to
stress damages but you also also have
damages purely for the infringement the
inability to control your own private
information so that's why the case is
looking at that angle in particular but
you're absolutely right I mean tomorrow
is going to be a very very different
experience from
um where the previous instances where
the Duke of Sussex has been able to
control the narrative and whether or not
that narrative has been the narrative
that the people have wanted to hear or
have appreciated it's it you know he
holds the cards and that's going to be
very different tomorrow when he's under
crosstalk yeah it really is and this
whole relationship with Chelsea might
come up again tomorrow because today in
court his lawyer said this he's little
more than a child as was Miss Davey at
the time it was if they never felt they
were on their own which placed a huge
amount of strain on their relationship
and ultimately LED Miss Davey to decide
a rule life wasn't for her it also
caused their circle of friends to become
smaller and smaller meaning that
relationships were lost entirely
unnecessarily
um tell me about this limitations
defense uh Persephone because a lot of
people will be thinking gosh Chelsea
Davey that's that's going back in time
time can he still bring that as a as an
example so for a case such as this
misuse of private information you have a
six year limitation period and what that
means is you have to commence the
proceedings within six years of either
the events taking place or you coming to
know of the events or should reasonably
have been expected to know that the
events took place now that is where the
argument lies in that in that sort of
grade because it's obviously a lot
longer than six years and it's the
limitation defenses which are being run
by the other newspapers and some of the
other cases that Harry's taking and
forward in relation to hacking and
bugging and unlawful information
gathering okay and we're just going to
talk about another relationship um Paul
and that is with his brother he says
that these articles just put a huge
strain on that relationship which of
course we know is has broken down this
is what Harry's lawyer said in court he
said Brothers can sometimes disagree but
once it's made public in this way and
inside feelings revealed in the way they
are trust becomes begins to be eroded I
mean his emotions are really raw well
they are but if you read spare closely
not even closely clearly there's a lot
of other things that have happened
between between him and William that
that actually uh play into the broken
down relationship between them so I'm
not sure how much how much you can put
on that particular you know episode
that's being that's being cited but of
course Harry and Harry Harry is fighting
two on two fronts here he's fighting in
the court of law but he's also fighting
in the court of opinion not just in
Britain but but Global public opinion
you know so to him it's a two-pronged
case it really is isn't it um well stay
where you are thank you very much uh so
far lots more still to come we'll have
more on what the lawyers said in court
today including from the Barrister who
will be cross-examining the Duke
tomorrow and will look ahead to Prince
Harry taking the stand don't go away
hello again and welcome back to our
special program now before the break we
outlined Harry's allegations now let's
discuss in a bit more detail the
newspapers defense the Barrister
representing mirror group newspapers has
disputed many of the claims put forward
by Prince Harry's lawyer Andrew Green
Casey said the following he said there
is no evidence to support a finding that
any mobile phone used by the Duke of
Sussex was hacked on even one occasion
still less that he was habitually hacked
there is no call data whatsoever for the
Duke of Sussex and scant for his
associates zilch zero nil NADA niente
absolutely nothing he said that is a
very difficult starting point that the
claimant was habitually hacked or even
hacked once Persephone Bridgeman Baker
media lawyer and partner at Carter Ruck
and Paul con you former editor of the
Sunday Mirror former of the former
deputy editors with the Daily Mirror
media commentator as well both here with
me now
um and we were talking about this early
Persephone he has got a point there
hasn't he yes he absolutely does um and
one of the other points which has been
counted by um by Harry's lawyer is
saying that look none of these
journalists who could give evidence on
any of these topics are being put
forward by the mirror group to give
evidence tomorrow award over the course
of the case so this is the other the
other twist which has been brought up
today I think is that that
um that statement which has been firmly
pressed by by David Sherman for for
Prince Harry yeah why is that do you
think why aren't we hearing from more
people who might be able to share
whether on some of this there are one or
two people who've been named by Sherman
ER in the in the hearings who of course
still have
um senior positions in in the mirror
group so it's not surprising that
Sherborne is saying well you know why
aren't they being called
um so it'd be interested integer to see
how you know you know how that that
transpires tomorrow but of course I
think one name is going to crop up
without a Shadow of Doubt is that
appears Morgan I think it's fair to say
that Harry Harry isn't the chairman of
the Piers Morgan admiration society and
vice versa yeah vice versa yeah and he's
always denied any knowledge of course uh
hasn't he
um uh but that is um uh an interesting
point isn't it that perhaps more people
haven't been called another something
else that was interesting when it comes
to the defense today Persephone was that
we heard in court that certain payments
had been made
um unlawful payments but those payments
aren't linked to any of the actual
articles that have been brought up by
Harry and uh the defense uh Barrister
for for the newspaper group saying well
what's going on here this seems a very
strange tactic it is definitely a case
put together on inference isn't it I
remember comments by um Duke of Sussex
says Barrister today saying well it's
obvious that or plainly it is that and
that just I think shows in law well it
depends how he doesn't has evidence and
it depends on how the the in
interestingly I think there's only three
um uh Witnesses on on the defendant side
and only one on the claimant side I mean
there are this is the same I suppose
could be levied um to the claimant side
of course which is that there are
presumably other people who could have
given given evidence um on behalf of
Harry but the judge will be entitled to
draw inference as Anna's being asked by
Harry's lawyer to draw inferences on the
basis of the fact that those journalists
responsible for some of those 33
articles aren't going to be giving
evidence because in other because in
other cases it's transpired of course
that where dubious payments were being
made you know the the exact and the
exact reason for the payments weren't in
the accounts Department shall we say so
that in itself will be a will be an
issue of uh an issue of an issue of
debate so it's it's going to be it's
going to be a very very interesting you
know day day tomorrow well let's talk
more about that then just before we we
close
um how is he going to do do you think in
the witness stand in the witness box
well he I think it's been estimated that
it's going to take at least a day and a
half and that's an extraordinarily long
time to be grooled by
um somebody who is out to pick holes in
your argument and I know everybody says
that if you're telling the truth you
shouldn't be worried about that at all
but you know as lawyers we talk about
litigation risk about your witness
waking up on the wrong side of bed and
just you know not not performing as well
as they they might do and particularly
for someone who's so used to the media
scrutiny and is used to being able to
control the narrative in the way that he
does it'll be very interesting to see
how that all pans out and Persephone
what how much can
Sherborne for for Harry intervene or
object during the course of the
cross-examination so he can make
objections but they have to be legal
objections he can't object to um to what
Harry is being is is saying he can't
sort of interrupt and I suppose we
always see that in you know American
courtroom dramas don't we yeah we do
it'll be a little more reserved tomorrow
although perhaps not not much more well
it's been fascinating getting your your
thoughts uh on all of this it is a
really interesting case isn't it
Persephone Paul thank you both and that
is day one the lawyers have set out the
arguments and as you've been hearing
tomorrow the Duke of Sussex will give
evidence his aim to prove that the story
is written about him were the result of
illegally obtained information and
ultimately change the media landscape
unlike his interviews of lay till have
little control over what happens in
course it will be unmissable and here on
Sky News we'll be back at nine o'clock
tomorrow night with a special program
and all the details from the high courts
good evening
foreign